Let's do this thing. So, we'll go to cell A2, Command, Shift, Right arrow key,
Command, Shift Down arrow key, highlighting all the data. Data, Sort range,
Sort by column B. And even though it says A to Z, that also applies for
numbers, from least to greatest. Ascending rather than descending, and then
Sort. And now, we have all our data sorted. Note that it starts in cell B2 and
goes to B28. Meaning, there are 27 values that we're interested in. And that
means our median is going to be this one, 479. With 479, we have 13 values
greater, and that's because we're going from cell 16, B16 until B28. So, we can
find that number of cells by just doing 28 minus 16 plus 1, that gives us 13.
And there are 13 values below 479. And likewise, we can do 14 minus 2 plus 1,
which gives us 13. So, here's our median in the 14th place. It says 15 here,
but that's because the data starts at cell 2. So, this is the 14th value.